Just as you can create a reflection vector to perform reflection mapping, you
can also create a refraction vector, and use that instead to access the
environment map. This can be combined with the color of the object to get
different variation of a material that looks a fair bit like glass. Snell's
Law's what's normally used for computing the refraction direction. It's named
after Willebrord Snellius, a Dutch astronomer and mathematician from the 17th
century. However, it turns out that Ibn Sahl, a Persian mathematician,
discovered this back in 984 A.D. This is an old formula and is as follows. In
this diagram, we have a ray of light traveling through, say, the air, and
hitting a transparent object, say, made of glass. In this equation, N1 and N2
are the index refraction of the air and glass respectively. The index of
refraction is a physical value for a material that is essentially how much
slower light travels through it compared to light in a vacuum. As examples,
here are some indexes of refraction. Air is just about 1, it's very close to
vacuum. Diamond is very different than glass and so that's one thing that
differentiates them. When the index of the refraction of the second material is
greater than the first the effect is that the sine of the angle must be smaller
to compensate. This means the angle from the normal becomes smaller. In other
words, light bends towards the normal when going from air to glass. The effect
is reversed when going in the other direction. Going from glass to air causes
the light to bend at a greater angle. This is what refraction mapping does. It
changes the direction of the light passing through the transparent object.
However, real objects have at least two refraction events when light passes
through them, both when entering and exiting the surface. Refraction mapping
does just the one refraction. Refraction mapping is not quite as convincing as
reflection mapping, in my opinion. Part of the reason is that the distortions
produced are not as complex as the real thing. More importantly, all that you
can ever see through these transparent objects is the environment map. Nothing
else. Notice that with the spheres demo, lovely as it is, that you can't see
any spheres through any other spheres. It's possible to make this happen, but
it is a lot of extra computation.